so there were so many games at
nintendo's April direct presentation
lots of really cool indie stuff but I
think one of the surprises maybe we're
expecting to hear something like Star
Fox or Zelda which had been delayed
recently we heard about another game
which had been resurrected which we
haven't heard about for like a year now
Shin Megami Tensei versus Fire Emblem I
know I that totally caught me off guard
when they were showing it and what
caught me off guard even more was that
they didn't really like preface the
video they just sort of like started
with a trailer and he's like really nice
graphics really colorful very elaborate
models and settings and I'm like what
those characters kind of look like
they're done by the firing boom artists
and there's my fantasy mixed with like
this is weird arena the kind of thing in
a modern era yeah then it looks really
good it was it so intriguing when it
starts out like I think I know what this
oh it's from Atlas I know this I don't
know what this game is and then it's
like the whole world opens up you're
like holy [ __ ] I can't believe you guys
haven't talked about this and so long
the game looks so good yeah like I think
if people are expecting a mix of
pre-existing like themes and motifs from
those games they're gonna be surprised
when they see this because it is almost
unrecognizable that it belongs to either
one of those universes apart from those
really small touches and I think I
picked up on but still couldn't place
and we don't know much more about it
than that like that trailer is it's the
extent of it we did learn some more
about fire emblem on 3ds which was also
kind of a surprise announcement last
year and it's kind of they're taking a
different tack with it which sounds
pretty intriguing yeah so I mean the
most basic thing they're doing
differently is that the character you
create is no longer a let's say a
companion to the main protagonists in
the plot you are going to be the main
character and with that what they're
doing is giving you a choice to join one
of two families that are in the middle
of a war that you have the whole channel
and the nor the hoshino are kind of like
the good guys there that's gonna be the
normal path and you know the path of
righteousness and they're fighting
against the noir who are kind of like
rebels in a little bit even they're
trying to take over the world they're
not the path of peace the way that it
changes things up i guess is hoshino is
going to be the more traditional way
that you play the game and they didn't
explain it exactly but if you're playing
on the north side it might be more
difficult that it's gonna
not be the typical way that you progress
through the game and we don't know it
exactly what that means but they
described it as functional is for maybe
beginners or people that just want that
traditional fireman experience and nor
is going to be the side that you take if
you play these games before and you want
something different or maybe even if
you're just playing through a second
time the characters the story and all
that's the same but the encounters and
their dialogue and all that you'll
change yeah I think it's a really smart
move on their part to mix things up
because Fire Emblem moves a series it
hasn't really changed a whole lot over
the years and they found great success
with the last one but if they would have
just put out another game that was sort
of the same old formula with new
dressing and a new story I don't know if
people would care as much and I think
people are really going to care about
this one probably like they're really
gonna care about shin megami tensei
versus our move as well I mean they're
both departures from the norm and that's
really great like that's cool to see
Nintendo supporting risky stuff if you
will for their platforms so it's really
exciting that they came out with all
this fire in lib news out of nowhere but
we're probably not going to hear
anything else about this until e3
you